in any normal year
phoenix lake reservoir would be nearly
full around now
today it's barely a third of that
the dry cracked mud the measure of what
officials say
is climate change in action in
california
i've been up here pretty frequently and
i think it's the last time was two or
three weeks ago and
just walking up here it's even drier
there's now an island in the middle of
our
reservoir that wasn't here when i was
here last time so you know we're
definitely seeing the impacts
we're in a historic drought right i mean
it's the driest you know 2020 was the
driest year in 90 years
this is um you know alarming and in some
ways i don't want to say expected but it
is clearly you know tied to climate
change you know the change in climate
you know everything we know from the
scientists is that climate change is
going to bring us droughts that are more
frequent
and more severe and more intense and
that's what we're experiencing
phoenix lake is one of seven reservoirs
that provide water to marin county
so low are the levels they've imposed
mandatory water restrictions
200 000 residents told not to fill their
pools or hot tubs
and stop washing their cars jens had
already replaced his lawns with
artificial grass
solar tiles helped power his home we
have to do it
to see what's happening now is going to
be severe
the restrictions he says are essential i
fully agree with it
it it has to otherwise
we're not going to get in here
i it's hardship but certainly we can
we can live with it from his house you
can see the bridge where in the 70s
they built a pipeline to bring water
across the bay
it's an option again now as the us
government agency that monitors the seas
and atmosphere confirmed an upward trend
in average temperatures
almost all of this the country's most
populous state is in drought
much of it classed as extreme the
numbers here are striking it's been
40 years since this water level was so
low and
only once in 140 years that they had
less rain
and yet what really worries them here is
that we're not even close
to those hot dry summer months
and about five miles away in the same
county sit the homes on stinson beach
which experts warn rising sea levels
could destroy within a generation
here the impacts of that climate change
future
have already arrived greg milam sky news
marin county in california